in my real life when i was a kid my mom
made me tuna noodle casserole and i have
to tell you i loved it
so much in fact whenever i see her now
as an adult i ask her
if she'll please make it for me because
the second i taste it it's like no time
has gone by whatsoever
so let's make nostalgic food fantasies
come true we're gonna make a classic
tuna noodle casserole
admit it you probably ate it growing up
too and if you didn't
well then it's something to look forward
to all right
we're going to start with our milk
right directly in the pot
then and this is the ultimate
ingredients
campbell's cream of mushroom soup i mean
i don't know if it's classified under
umami
but it should be because
it's like you can't really emulate this
taste
okay then we're gonna go straight for
the tuna
right in the pot i have to say too
like i love a one-pot meal the way that
i started to learn how to cook
was by soups not only are they actually
really complex and a lot of chefs
get tested in restaurants when they're
going for jobs on how to make a soup
because it's not
easy but i love one concentrated area
that whole like
multitasking in the kitchen is not
really
my jam yet so this is it and you just go
round and round um okay so
there we've got that now we're going to
put it right
into a baking dish
or in the 50s it probably would have
been corningware
okay there you go so again
from one pot to another you're going to
want to even that
out because you're going to want to add
breadcrumbs on top
so we're going to go over to our bread
crumbs we're going to
put some melted butter right into it
because at this point you're eating
noodles and cream of mushroom soup so
just if you're going down go all the way
french's fried onions okay so you kind
of want to
make this come together almost like a
roux
and then that's right arthur
and then we're just gonna put that right
on top because a classic
tuna noodle casserole is ultimately a
casserole and casseroles have this
beautiful
baked top it's like when you get one of
those incredibly decadent macaroni and
cheeses and you're like i don't need
that and then you start eating it you're
like
i need that
so then you're going to put this in the
oven
for 15 minutes at 400 degrees and when
it comes out
you're going to have this gorgeous
golden brown
what do you think mom how did i do
trust me i'll get a text about it later
okay so
i know this may sound shocking to you
but our very own food stylist
uli has never she does all of this
beauty that you see
at the top of our shots anyway uli
has never tasted tuna noodle casserole
so
uli will you come and taste the tuna
noodle casserole
[Music]
okay fun welcome fun fact by the way
uli has always worn a denim jumpsuit in
the kitchen
i feel like we were meant to be together
all right
cheers cheers and
it's not bad
i thought he was revolting when i heard
it but this is actually
i know it's not bad again my beautiful
niece sadie clarkman always says don't
yuck my yum
it's noodles and creaminess and
yeah thank you nice glass of wine
i love being a co-pilot in the kitchen
with you
well it's the best place and we look
like a couple of denim pilots
let me shoot it ooly cheers to you
thank you